بالنسبه للمعدات الموجوده داخل المطار هل
معروف من يسيطر على ماذا ان الجيش فعلا
يسيطر على كل المطار بما فيه
[موسيقى]
طبعا هناك وجود لقوات الدعم السريع داخل
مطار مروي الدولي وكذلك يقوم كما اظهر
اظهرت صور يعني كان حريصا
على ان تكون ان تخرج الى الاعلن هذه الصور
الصور الصور كانت تظهر مجموعه من
العسكريين من الجيش السوداني ومعهم مجموعه
من العسكريين المصريين بينهم الضباط
مصريون يعني في قبضه الدعم السريع داخل
المطار ولكن الجيش السوداني يقول انه يطوق
المطار بشكل كامل ولا يريد ان يعني ان
يهجم على
المطار بشكل مباشر
للمحافظه على سلامه الاسرى السودانيين
والازرى المصريين ولكن قال انه يحكم خبطته
الكامل على مطار مرايا الدولي طبعا هذه
الروايه مخالفه تماما لما اوردته قوات
الدعمه سريع في منصاتها المخ
قد رسمت واقعا جديدا على هذه المدينه منذ
صباح امس وحتى هذه اللحظه ولكن الى اين
والى متى ستكون هذه الاحوال لا احد يدري
حتى هذه اللحظه ماذا عن الاسرى هل اسامه
معروفه انهم بالضبط
اذا كررت السؤال لما استمع بالنسبه للاسرى
ماذا عن موقعهم
لصور الاولى التي يبثتها قوات الدعم
السريعه كانت تشير الى ان هؤلاء الاسرى
داخل مطار مروي الدولي الاسرى الذين ظهروا
في الصوره يتبعون للجيش السوداني وكذلك
مجموعه من العسكريين المصريين داخل مطار
مروي الدولي تحدثنا مع الجيش السوداني من
مصادر مصادر استخباراتيه في الجيش
السوداني اكدت لنا ان مجموعه كبيره من
الاسرى الذين يتبعون لقوات الدعم السريع
الان هم في قبضه الجيش السوداني في مكان
ما لم
يكشف لنا المصدر الاستخباري الاستخباراتي
مكان المكان الذي يعني
يخبئون فيه هؤلاء الاسرى ولكن الاسرى في
في العموم ربما اذا ما تغيرت الاحوال
وتبدلت وهدات الاحوال ربما نحاول ان نقترب
من المشهد من جد يعني اكثر فاكثر كما سمحت
الظروف الامنيه واذا ما يعني استجابت
الاوضاع
التي تعتبر حتى هذه اللحظه اوضاع خطيره
ولا يمكن
معها سهوله الحركه بشكل امن ومستقر اذا ما
اردنا الوصول الى قلب الاحداث الداخليه
سواء كان داخل مطار مروي الدولي او اي
مركز
لهذه الاشتباكات التي كانت تتركز في جهه
الجنوب الغربي في محيط مطار مروي الدولي
ولكن طبعا مطار الدوله الواحد هو من اهم
المناطق الحساسه والاستراتيجيه لانه ليس
مجرد مطار مدني فقط ولكن يتبع
للقوات هو قائد عسكريه قاعده جويه تتبع
للجيش السوداني وفيها مجموعه من الله
الطائرات الحربيه وكذلك مطار مروي الدولي
هو يعد المطار الثاني بعد مطار الخرطوم
وطالما انه قبل نحو شهرين او اكثر اعتبرته
الجهات الحكوميه او
سلطه الطيران المدني هو المطار البديل
لمطار الخرطوم الدولي وبالتالي يمكن ان
نقول انه المطار الثاني في البلاد شكرا لك
اسامه سيد احمد كنت معنا من مروي